what i wanted to have like peaceful  enjoyable night with my friends would  you just do  to to my fiance it's supposed to be a  very positive  funny night and i'm kind of disappointed  from all this  i don't know why i should do better to  don't get to this point did i do  something wrong  did i see something wrong i don't know  but in the game i know i'm gonna be my  fault no matter what  why did you walk away  i just didn't feel right being there in  that moment i just  i just didn't really feel  loved by you and respected and i just  felt like i needed to just  own my own self-worth and  left with stacy and wanted to go home i  just don't want to talk about it right  now i'm tired  of respecting what i do to make you feel  no love and respect i i just honestly  feel like i want to  go to sleep right now i feel very  drained and i can't even think anymore  can i just please go to bed nobody's  helping you  go to bed okay  [Music]  [Music]  you